j'accueille maintenant patrick dils
e
il
bonsoir patrick bruno solo yvan le
bolloc'h liane foly patrick dils alors
patrick dils vous avez été condamné à la
prison à perpétuité pour avoir avoué le
meurtre de deux petits garçons alexandre
et cyril c'était en 1986 à montigny les
metz et quinze ans après lors de votre
troisième procès après 15 ans de prison
les jurés vous emportant reconnu
innocent et vous ont acquitté vous
raconter cette tragédie qui vous a coûté
votre jeunesse
dans un livre intitulé je voulais juste
rentrer chez moi
publié chez michel lafon paul ferrère
alors je voulais juste rentrer chez moi
le titre du livre amène directement à ce
que vous dites
lorsque vous avez été arrêté pour
expliquer vaut aveu vous avouer le
double meurtre des enfants pour que
l'inspecteur en fait tout simplement
vous laisse rentrer chez vous après
trois jours et deux nuits de garde à vue
pour retrouver votre votre papa et votre
maman ouais tout à fait si vous voulez
ça s'est passé de la manière suivante
lorsque j'ai été arrêté le 28 avril 1987
pour la troisième fois la fac était donc
décisive
j'ai déjà été entendu pendant de
nombreuses heures et j'ai toujours dit
la vérité et dans la soirée ma mère a
téléphoné donc au commissarait police
ânesse et a demandé à l'inspecteur vers
l'est si c'était une heure pour
interroger un mineur et s'il ne pouvait
pas plus tôt interrogé le lendemain
matin
ça se fait un peu plus convenable et
celui là vraiment énervé pas content de
la réaction de ma mère a dégoté un ami
si si c'est encore moi qui commande
de toute manière votre fils il sera
interrogé le temps nécessaire afin qu'il
nous dise la vérité et
il ne sera pas tranquille avant alors là
écoutez voir ça faisait des heures que
je disais la vérité
ouais lorsque l'on entend un inspecteur
dire à sa propre mère il sera tranquille
qu'à partir du moment où on dira la
vérité
il ya une réaction qui se fait si vous
disais donc l'inspecteur céder si tu
racontes tout tu pourra rentrer chez toi
tu pourras aller travailler demain matin
là sauf que problème c'est en cellule
que vous êtes entré et que vous
rentrerez chez vous seulement 15 en
retard
autre raison de 2 vous avez les insultes
les brimades les menaces de mort dit
vous dans votre livre de la part de ce
que vous appelez avec une certaine
ironie les gardiens de la paix c'est à
dire qu'ils vous ont forcé à avouer le
meurtre des deux enfants et j'aiderai
qui m'ont amené vous savez on pourrait
considérer ça à l entonnoir
oui et avec une sortie il n'y avait pas
36 même temps qu'ils n'avaient pas
obtenu ce qu'il souhaitait obtenir soit
pas été tranquille
alors c'est vrai aussi que de toute
façon chez vous on avait beaucoup de
respect pour les pour les représentants
de l'ordre donc ça vous sembler naturel
presque de de faire ce que vous dites et
c'était des adultes se représenter en
plus autorité tout ce que mes parents
avaient un culte et au respect des
adultes nous revient sur l'autorité des
personnes âgées donc effectivement
ouais c'était compliqué un petit peu car
autrement alors autre raison de vous
avez aussi deux hommes avaient avoué
avant vous avez joué successivement être
les meurtriers des deux petits garçons
avant de se rétracter sans plus de
problèmes
ce qu'amy drôle de région n'a pas
continué d'émettre quand il ya deux
enfants qui sont mis à trois personnes
innocentes qui avoue m était majeure
problème c'est que vous on vous garde
alors contrairement à ce que vous pensez
effectivement les policiers se rendent
pas compte que vous mentez à ce moment
là si vous vous dites à un moment ils
vont comprendre que je raconte un
mensonge et je pense qu'ils en doutent
et de massa était à partir du moment où
il ya une enquête de voisinage est sans
aucune arrière pensée sans aucune
méchanceté sans l'intention de nuire la
justice lorsqu'on a demandé à ma mère si
on avait vu ou entendu quelque chose
j'étais à côté d'elle dans les escaliers
de la maison eh ben j'ai pas dis tout
simplement ce que j'avais vu entendu ce
soir l'homme pourquoi j'avais pas eu
l'intention de leur mentir mais
uniquement parce que je ne pensais pas
un seul instant à ce moment là que ce
que j'avais pu voir ou entendre aurait
peut-être déterminant au capital pour la
suite des événements alors je parlais de
retrouver vos parents votre envie
irrépressible de rentrer à la maison de
quitter le commissariat et cette maison
était importante pour vous parce que
pour vous la cour de récréation c'était
un peu le cauchemar il faut dire des
choses
patrick j'étais un petit peu le souffre
douleur de la classe gt le
souffre-douleur de la classe et pour
être tout à fait honnête
les deux seuls endroits où je me sentais
vraiment très bien et évident c'était
dans ma famille chez mes parents et sur
mon lieu de travail
ouais alors on nous appelait le fil de
fer parce que vous êtes un
un peu grand rouquin le cas là parce que
j'avais une mauvaise démarche rambo
parce que je suis tout le contraire
ouais enfin j'ai eu droit à tous les
styles de brimades et anne harris et
patrimoine va fair frag et donc les gars
on se moque de vous parce que vous avez
un grand nez vous êtes grand une drôle
de démarche est un peu maladroit un peu
gauche peut-être un peu gauche jamais et
vous vous riposté pas non je suis
toujours parti du principe quand ils en
ont marre ils arrêteront voyager pas
partisan de la violence c'est depuis
pour moi la violence engendre la
violence donc mais qui pâtissent en
auront marre ils arrêteront tout
simplement
et donc cette habitude que vous aviez
prise de paris poster finalement dans la
cour de l'école
c'est la même attitude c'est tout ce que
je veux dire là c'est la même attitude
que vous avez en face de l'inspecteur de
police donc que tu as fait ouais donc
vous vous laissez faire un peu un petit
peu comme dans la voie ferrée c'est tout
simplement sagna on va dire qu'il ya
j'étais vraiment un enfant qui sortait
d'un cocon familial vraiment bien d'un
construit bien prenant et j'étais tout
le contraire vraiment tout le contraire
d'un enfant des banlieues
parce que si j'étais vraiment sorti
d'une banlieue premier rang devant
l'inspecteur voire les mois je vais
retourner son bureau et qui voudra pas
dire ce que j'ai pas envie mais bon
j'étais un peu trop d'où un peu trop
bien janvier proviennent élevé oui pis y
avait donc comme on disait chez vos
parents qui sont des gens modestes
il y avait un respect dites vous des des
grands de ce monde les gens qui sont
inaccessibles vous dites il ya une
espèce de complexe par rapport aux
classes sociales plus élevées vous que
j'étais un petit peu on peut dire dans
les jupes de votre maman j'ai dernière
pas peur des mots effectivement si la
philatélie des maquettes s'agit d'une
maquette un nom un monde particulier
envers allemande que je m'étais créé oui
puisque j'étais un peu rejetés par
rapport aux autres mais il fallait bien
un univers bien sûr alors c'est cet
univers est artificielle c'est dans une
espèce de cocon comme ça qui alors
tellement enfants à sa maman que vous
étiez vierge
à l'époque donc vous êtes entré en
prison vierge et vous l'êtes encore vous
dites je suis vierge car je refuse de
considérer le viol dont j'ai été victime
en prison comme une première fois ça n'a
rien à voir l'acte d'amour dit vous vous
réveillez connaître un jour tu as fait
je prends je prends un coup de foudre je
crois que l'amour c'est quelque chose
qui se mérite quelque chose qui se
respecte c'est quelque chose de beau et
vous savez quand on a pu patienter
quinze ans on pouvait patienter ciment
et on doit encore patienter un petit peu
plus alors avant ce violent qui est
important parce que ça ça démontre au
delà de votre cas personnel la façon
dont les choses se passent en prison
c'est un fils aîné épouvantable quand on
lit votre bouquin avant ce viol donc
qu'il ya eu toujours comme l'humiliation
dans la cour de récréation
il ya eu des problèmes avec les
codétenus parce que effectivement gipa
faut se mettre à leur place
enfin pour eux vous êtes quand même un
meurtrier d'enfants a fait rêver le
nôtre d'enfants c'est parce qu'il faut
savoir que dans une prison il ya une
hiérarchie sociale
et oui le meurtre d'enfants 6-4 plus
basse et de plus détestable
de plus répréhensibles au sein même des
murs
donc non seulement il je devais
affronter la justice
je devais affronter le monde pénal mais
également l'écho dating les coudes
détenus qui se privait pas de vous
frapper alors vous dites avec un torchon
moulié ou alors avec une chaussette dans
laquelle il mettait une savonnette et en
général les gens qui sont en prison pour
les délits vraiment crapuleux et bien il
ne supporte pas leur propre délit alors
pour justement essayer entre guillemets
de le supporter eh ben ils essaient de
trouver pire que oui et puis justement
de se venger pour oublier leurs propres
problèmes mais dit patrick dils avoir eu
honte de votre manque de courage face à
ces corrections
ben oui parce que j'aurais aimé avoir la
force le courage d'avancer le courage de
riposter le courage de dire stop
maintenant ça suffit il faut réagir
mais là encore cette hausse est due à
une éducation c'est dû à mon caractère
on change pas le caractère d'une
personne en un claquement de doigts
saviez vous excusez moi vous aviez pas
trouvé un ami sur lequel vous appuyez
parce qu'il ya aussi une certaine
solidarité qui peut s'installer parfois
dans la prison quelqu'un qui est plus
sûr plus attentifs qui peut comprendre
lorsque vous y avez parlé tout de notre
problème puisque est-ce que vous est
confiée en prison en disant je suis
innocent parce que vous l'avez clame et
rien n'est fait que ça m'a montré que
j'ai pu une fois rencontré des gens qui
ont été extrêmement servir vraiment
gentil des gens qui ont voulu se
substituer au rôle de père et dire
maintenant tu laisses plus laisse
tranquille le monde
ce qu'il a fait c'est pas à toi d'en
juger le temps qui sera avec moi tu leur
as 4 a pas plu touchera pas sinon c'est
moi même en affaires heureusement elle
des gens comme station et là je leur
tire mon chapeau parce qu'alain quand
certains qui sont aujourd'hui en prison
d'autres qui sont sortis parce qu'il
faut savoir que la prison c'est un petit
peu comme une balance roberval vous avez
les très mauvais moment là je peux en
parler en connaissance de cause
mais heureusement pour moi et puis pour
mes proches qui ont toujours cru en moi
il ya eu des moments extraordinaires et
c'est un moment extraordinaire pardon
qui ont permis de garder les deux poêles
la balance j'ai à peu près ajusté qui
veut dire que quand vous êtes victime de
de brimades ou de correction de la part
de vos codétenus
les matons sont jamais là ils sont
jamais là quand il faut
vous savez je pense que c'est un peu
comme la police at on a besoin d'elle
elle n'est pas là que quand on n'a pas
besoin d'aller en revanche les matons
ils sont toujours là pour mater un dans
les douches
quand vous prenez votre douche a
toujours un qui se met au milieu comme
ça qui regarde un peu ce qui se passe
il n'y a pas de nouveau les douches vous
savez layton on dit que c'est pour la
sécurité du détenu mais aussi c'est un
bon moyen pour le voyeurisme
mouais on traite très souvent le détenu
d'être pervers
avant de dire que c'est un homosexuel
ouais vous savez ils sont pas et belle
aux côtés de l'oeil
les fouilles aussi vous parler des fous
ils sont traités les uns pour faire des
fouilles à huy les fruits sont vraiment
particulière au niveau les parloirs
heureusement elles ont évolué ces
dernières années
mais en dix ans à toul j'ai eu à faire à
certains surveillants
tu connaissais aucun problème
connaissant mon parcours dont
évasivement parloir passe un bon moment
et pierre d'autres dont la fouille à
corps normal puis d'autres vous et moi
j'ai des yeux pour regarder les yeux on
voyait bien là où ils s'arrêtaient donc
avec union d'assistance c'est cette
série parce qu'on se sent en cent mille
y est là et tu attends quoi là qu'est ce
que tu veux et là encore on peut rien
dire parce que eux ils ont le nez forme
et non la peur c'était bien sûr celle
hornets est plus humain terrifiant
d'abord qu'on lui remette en question
est toujours bien de se justifier
toujours en train d'expliquer alors
qu'ils ont dit oui
la cour d'assises jugera ou la
correctionnelle ou jugeant non c'est
continuellement c'est un jour et c'est
là qu'à cette date assez importante
finalement on va le voir mais très très
dramatique pour vous c'est le viol quoi
c'est à dire que finalement votre
premier contact sexuel dans votre vie ça
a été ce violent et c'est à partir de là
que vous décidez de réagir de relever la
tête et
et du plus rien accepté et je dirais que
c'est la goutte qui a fait déborder le
vase
mais il ya d'autres choses bien avant
c'est à dire que au départ quand je suis
en prison par à pau par rapport à toutes
les vannes que j'avais pu subir à
l'école
et puis bien d'ailleurs je suis tombé
avec un codétenu
kim à une fois vu en sortant la douche
dans la cellule en train de me regarder
le visage dans le miroir et puis en
train ne pas être satisfait de mon
propre visage la dirait que patrick a
hâte de déconner là parce que t'as rien
de me prendre la tête ça va pas
je t'ai rien fait dit non mais sa forme
a dit mme ikeda en miroir la ta les
boutons à des moutons qu'est ce que tu
veux ttp ou qui te plaît pas maintenant
je me plaît pas je n'aime pas et puis
alors la mise du ces pour pouvoir aimer
les autres il faut d'abord que tu
puisses te mets toi même et je serai pas
très bien saisir ce qu'ils voulaient me
faire comprendre cette personne faisait
de la peinture
et puis il m'a mis dans la salle de
peinture m'a dit vous de voir qu'est ce
que tu vois sur ce tableau
ben écoute moi je vois ça ça et puis ça
hennit tu vois là moi je regarde la même
toile que toi eh bien je vois pas du
tout la même chose que toi
l'être humain c'est un peu comme une
toile poids qui va me plaire
la personne qui sera à côté de moi qui
me plaira pas alors à partir du moment
où tu as pris conscience de ça va tu as
fait un grand pas et là ça a été le
premier clic bien sûr y en a eu il y en
a eu beaucoup
avant le viol vous raconter l'histoire à
un scénario classique
et après avoir fait son truc quoi le mec
vous laisse là un truc planté au milieu
de la cellule et puis à quatre pattes et
quatre pattes et puis vraiment humiliée
honteux
j'étais là je pouvais pas réagir j'étais
j'avais les larmes aux yeux gt gt
soulier gt gt nortis dans la chair et
croyez moi
très honnêtement si on n'avait pas forcé
la cour d'assises de lyon d'en parler je
n'en n'aurai jamais parlé si je dis tout
ça concrètement dans le livre c'est pour
que ça soit dit une fois pour toutes
qu'on comprenne bien qu'en prison mais
se passe pas toujours les choses saint
catholiques quelque chose qui pourrait
être évité et que malheureusement les
gens ferment les yeux ça c'est honteux
et inadmissible et que masque et un vers
moi il faut plus de ça arrive à un autre
parce que vous savez quand une femme se
fait violer elle a honte elle veut pas
en parler
elles sont sales alors imaginez un seul
instant quand il a été pendant cette
chose abominable arrive à un homme mais
c'est le ciel cliton sur la tête c'est
je sais encore aujourd'hui alors que ça
fait plus de dix ans est arrivé c'était
comme si c'était hier je peux pas c'est
s'écouter c'est terrible c'est terrible
et il en restera des traces je pense à
vie parce que ça fait mal non quelque
chose alors je rapprocher cette cette
scène que vous décrivez dans votre
bouquin d'une phrase de vous vous dites
je vais devenir un homme digne qui
marchent la tête haute qui tient la main
de ses enfants dans la rue et qui sourit
à sa femme on voit très bien
l'opposition des deux images voilà un
président à libération première
sensation de liberté et ses traits à
quoi ça tient
c'est le moins lieu des coussins d'une
voiture un oui est ce que je me suis
effondrée dans le fauteuil pas
l'habitude d'être assis dans un canapé
les choses très simples les étoiles
le vent les odeurs et vous avez au bord
de l'eau jeu pour regarder le couler oui
j'ai l'impression que les gens ne savent
plus apprécié la juste valeur de cette
liberté qui est tellement belle qui est
magique et ça ne peut plus voir que
l'egypte vanter peu n'importe quoi
moi je suis toujours content de vous
écouter les gens lui à faire beau ils
vont se plaindre il va pleuvoir
ils vont se plaindre qu'ils allaient
impôts à payer ils vont se plaindre mais
quand est ce qu'ils seront heureux pour
être heureux je pense qu'il faut qu'il
soit pleinement satisfait et puis
surtout ce qui est important c'est à
dire et je pense que c'est que moi
malheureusement j'étais dans une
véritable prison il y avait de vrais mur
il y avait de vrais barreau de vraies
clés devraient bruit de vraies violences
mais contrairement à tout ça je pense
qu'ils en moins 50% de la population qui
se met elle-même dans une prison
virtuelle et là ça c'est grave c'est
très très grave parce que elles sont
contre elle se contrôle plus elles mêmes
elles sont belles sont bouffés par la
vie est là c'est dramatique c'est
dramatique
la vie elle est tellement belle comment
vous avez eu le courage de tenir tout
c'est tout ce qui vous est arrivé ça
vous êtes croyant vous avez des choses
profondes ne vous en faites vous savez
la religion c'est quelque chose qui m'a
qui m'a détruit en prison au niveau de
la cour d'assises parce que ça a été
très très mal interprété ou d'une phrase
lorsque je on me demande si je suis
croyant je dis oui
avez vous quelque chose à vous faire
pardonner je dis oui en pensant à tous
les mensonges que j'avais pu dire et sur
le procès-verbal s'était tapé le mot
meurt donc ça c'est ça vous avez dit
encore plus si vous ne pas maintenir le
dollar miné
je voulais simplement qu'effectivement
j'ai une certaine croyance
je suis convaincu qu'il existe quelque
chose
qu'il ya une force divine mais tout
simplement si je suis aujourd'hui ici
devant vous c'est avant tout par rapport
à moi-même
par rapport à ma propre innocence par
rapport à mes parents par rapport à mon
frère alain par rapport à mes avocats
par rapport à mai mais comité de soutien
par rapport à tous ceux qui ont cru en
moi et qu'il aujourd'hui même
profondément et c'est pour eux je me
suis battu j'ai évidemment pour moi la
voix parce que je l'étais j'étais
innocent mais eux m'ont donné cette
énergie est l'élément de me battre mère
extraordinaire c'est un roc c'est extra
c'est qu'elle a complètement changé à
l'heure actuelle elle est devenue elle a
fondu et les contrecoups maintenant
rouler contre le contrecoup m'a pas fait
que votre mère a dit simon fils était
était coupable j'aurai en mai moi même à
la police et après je me serais suicidé
la sagesse a jeté un froid pour la 6
on a bien vu que c'était quelque chose
qui n'était pas préparé c'était une
triste réalité
or voilà le grand moment aussi donc à
cette première sensation de liberté donc
les coussins de la voiture ça a l'air de
rien mais bon et puis ensuite vous
retournez dans votre maison maison
familiale à montigny-lès-metz et là vous
retrouvez vous retrouver les timbres
vous retrouvez les puzzles vous
retrouver les les maquettes je
retrouvais tout ce que j'avais laissé
que 16 ans après l'odeur de créer l
odeur de colle 16 ans après vous
retrouver c'est on va dire que les
premières réactions
on aurait pu éventuellement me comparer
à un petit show qui va courir dans
toutes les pièces
tellement content de retrouver quelque
chose qu'il a connus ou quelque chose de
tout nouveau qui est très important pour
lui donc ça peut faire sourire mais je
sens que j'en attendais sait si bien
représentative parce que ça m'a
tellement manqué j'ai tellement rêver
comme à cette liberté
vous savez je dirais que tout le monde
ce drame qui a duré 15 ans il ya eu une
première victoire
c'est quand la cour de cassation a pris
la
grande décision de casser la décision de
la cour d'assises de la moselle en 89 et
de me donner une nouvelle chance pour
une prochaine cour d'assises
ça c'est la première victoire la seconde
victoire est la plus belle pour tous
ceux qui ont cru en moi c'est très bien
évidemment l'acquittement et au
troisième procès je veux dire
honnêtement
en ce qui me concerne ça a été une
victoire certes mais j'ai pas sauter de
joie au plafond j'ai pas été aussi
heureux que tous ceux qui ont cru en moi
l'ont été pour moi tout simplement parce
que si vous voulez je récupérer ce qu'on
avait volé
quinze ans plus tôt et qu'on me rendais
c'était pour moi légitime c'était juste
et normal donc je vais pas sauter au
plafond d'heures par contre la troisième
et la plus belle des victoires c'est
quand je serai qu'est ce qui s'est passé
sur ce talus le 28 septembre 1986 et
pourquoi on a enlevé la vie à ses deux
petites victimes qui ne souhaitait
qu'une chose vivre grandir et réussir
comme moi leur vie effectivement quand
vous retournez à montigny-lès-metz
vous allez sur ce tas lui dire qu'on
vous dit mais en fait tu vas pas aller
là du mais que vous agirez pas j'ai rien
j'ai rien à me reprocher je peux aller
voir la roumanie zelos c'est comme la
réponse à mousson avait comme l'avenue
des champs-elysées c'est une rue comme
les autres qui les a tués ces moments là
je peux pas vous répondre je n'en sais
rien francis heaulme à je ne permettrai
jamais de dire francis heaulme est
l'auteur des faits pour la bonne et
simple raison qu ayant passé 15 ans en
prison et ayant été innocent monsieur ce
grâce de ce drame terrible est atroce
je ne peux pas me permettre d'accuser
quelqu'un ça serait très dramatique
maintenant à la justice faire son
travail et surtout j'espère que cette
justice ne mettra pas 15 ans pour
trouver la vérité parce que si moi je
veux savoir ce qui s'est passé
j'estime que les parents méritent encore
plus que moi de savoir la vérité afin
qu'il puisse enfin faire le deuil
de leurs deux enfants et espérer
survivre parce qu'on ne vit pas un drame
patrick dit je ne sais pas si vous
disiez je sais pas si je suis croyant en
tous les cas vous êtes chrétien je peux
vous le dire parce que vous vous
pardonner aux parents des deux petites
victimes qui continue à dire que c'est
vous le coupable
et vous vous avez cette charité
chrétienne de dire bah finalement je
comprends qu'ils pensent ça je leur en
veux pas c'est pas de leur faute ils ont
souffert et c'est de ces beaux parce
qu'il continue à vous accusez 14h qu'il
vous a hissé aujourd'hui on leur dit de
changer de coupables c'est difficile
de quelle façon la justice qu'on peut
réparer son erreur à votre endroit côté
lâché obligé de sourire mais avec aso
est très très jeune et très noir très
très dur parce que la justice pourra
faire ce qu'elle veut à mon égard
qu'elle me donne tout l'or du monde
ou qu'elle me donne le franc symbolique
honnêtement les 15 ans qui sont écoulés
là vous savez c'est comme une cigarette
ces partis en fumée c'est lui qu'on fume
est hélas plus rien qui me rendra ses 15
ans mais c'est à dire pardon mais je
peux dire à yvan des gens qui ont été
victimes d'erreurs judiciaires comme
patrick dils reçoivent 400 mille francs
300 mille francs 500 mille francs 150
mille francs dire c'est pas des sommes
qu'ils valent 15 ans de la vie de
quelqu'un de toute façon il n'y a aucune
sun qu'il vaut donc en tous les cas ce
sont de très petites sommes là ce soir
là vous êtes bien ça va extrêmement
heureux heureux de vivre de pouvoir
faire partager mon expérience
malheureusement la triste expérience de
la vie et puis comme je lé également moi
j'ai pu le confier
bon là c'est encore un peu tôt parce que
ça fait à peine six mois que je suis
devenu un homme libre oui
aussi honnête que vous je dirais c'est
que quand les problèmes matériels seront
réglés eh ben je compte faire du social
je compte mettre à profit
encore une fois ça très triste
expérience dans les écoles primaires
pour faire prendre conscience aux
enfants que la liberté c'est quelque
chose de magique qui font prendre soin
qu'il faut faire très attention et un
côté beaucoup plus je dirais plus plus
fort c'est aller dans les écoles de
magistrature il les écoles de police
oui et puis leur faire comprendre que
leurs décisions qui sont amenés à
prendre plus tard elles sont très lourds
de conséquences et qu'il fasse très
attention avant de se prononcer sur
quelqu'un ou sur quelque chose alors
vous vivez comment votre autorité parce
que là c'est un peu comme si vous
sortiez du lot la l'a déjà le mollah ne
me plaît pas du tout à la notoriété
j'ai souvent entendu il ya deux mois la
star là la vedette je suis une star nous
une vedette je suis une victime du
système judiciaire
ouais je pense que je le dis très bien
dans le livre il y en a qui vont qui met
toute une vie pour devenir célèbre moi
je vais mettre le restant de mes jours
pour retourner dans l'anonymat
j'aspire pas grand chose je ne demande
pas à décrocher la lune a fondé un foyer
à réussir à la vie professionnelle
avoir un commerce puisque c'est le mon
rêve depuis l'âge de 9 ans vous ne
feriez pas resteront une pâtisserie je
sais pas encore mais dans le domaine de
la bouche et puis être heureux vivons
vivre simplement avant un cercle d'amis
c'est peut enfin de pointe donc comme
n'importe qui je pense que j'y ai droit
au début vous êtes venu à paris
travailler en épices aux astres et c'est
un oui j'ai
la chance de tomber sur des patrons
vraiment excellent charmant qui ont fait
une approche remarquable à mon égard et
puis à l'égard de mon frère qu'est ce
qui m'a accompagné un personnel
remarquez également mais c'est je suis
parti c'est pas parce que l'emploi me
convenait pas c'est pas parce que
j'avais des difficultés avec le patron
c'est pas parce que j'avais des
difficultés
un matin un gros niveau la société la
société mais simplement parce que je ne
pouvais pas vivre à paris j'étais en
train de tomber malade pour vous
comprenez bien ce que je pouvais en
sentir à ce moment là c'est comme quand
vous sortez de là manège vraiment qui
vous qui vous donne le tournis et non
c'était trop dur pour le mois et on l'a
très vite compris qu'il fallait le faire
partir de là parce que sinon j'aurais pu
faire du mal mais pas du mal à autrui
peuvent faire du mal
un modem et puis peut-être
on arrive à des situations dramatiques
alors avant de se quitter
patrick dils je vais lire un mail de
gabriel tessier que j'ai reçu puisque
donc maintenant les téléspectateurs
peuvent envoyer des mails en fonction
des invités qui sont sur le plateau
c'est une dame de colmar elle m'écrit ce
n'est pas une question c'est juste un
mot pardon pardon parce que c'est au nom
du peuple français que vous avez été
condamné
non là civil
je vais juste parler c'est noir
et